this little step as you go on this is
what you're paying on an annual basis or
monthly basis and then what happens in
between each of those payments increases
because interest okay so this is the
whole concept of an annuity that you're
making regular payment and in addition
to those regular payments it's growing
just because of interest that's you what
you have investment will do so the
regular store that is usually annual
which is why we call it an annuity now
if that's what you do suppose this
little regularly so it's like $1,000
okay and it grows and grows and grows
and grows and after I learned one two
three four five six seven years is what
I happen to draw my graph after seven
years it has grown to this event we have
a need for what's internal about ends up
being in the future what to call future
value so when you go through the future
value formula or you go to a future
value table what you're calculating is
this melbeck anomaly absolutely what
your future is calculating is this huge
value Kia right and it grows really
quickly which is why you had a look in
the future value table you know a single
dollar becomes $7 $13 $20 if it's in
ever a long period of time so that's
what future value is calculating for you
however we contemplate this idea that
that's not the only way to get this you
don't have to just get there by regular
installments
alternatively if you want to end up at
the same teacher value there's a single
lump table that you could invent that if
you just stuck into the bank and you
didn't touch it you just let it grow by
preparing just over the same amount of
time for the same interest rate what do
we call this money right now in the
present we call it the present
now our present values we define as the
amount of money the blood some you'd
have to invest today hence the name
present value in order to end up at that
same amount but what we looked at most
recently at the end of last week whether
you can also use this to try and
understand if your repiy alone to
remember that if you are trying to
repair loader you try and work out well
how much should I pay off today on a
monthly basis to pay off my debt then
essentially the present value former is
example two to be or the present value
table okay so here's a picture of what
each of these are doing this is for
credit right it's for credit so you can
see you've got an annuity and it's
growing over time but what the rest of
today's reading account is borrowing
okay so if you've got your laptop there
what I'd like to go to is 8s there's no
explanation provided to you to a debt
because these are graphs that we've seen
before we've just never interpreted them
in the context okay so the first thing I
want to do is I'll even put them
side-by-side for a moment you can see
the graph that I just drew is going on
and this graph over here is going down
and that's because I have a big why is
it why are you dropping like then on
three million yeah okay I think I said
the same way in two different words are
what you're putting money in so your
value is growing one you're where you're
putting money in you try to repay
something it's a debt and therefore
you'd expect you've heard bits getting
smaller there's nothing cents
okay so let's interpret this as soon as
you also need your calculator there so
let's try to work out what's going on
this is a graph of the balance owing so
this person has for $250,000
then in interest rate and there's a
period of time I also tell you that the
monthly payment is what does it sends a
good a $99 so the bluegrass the top one
is what happens if you
at this rate but of course you don't
have to go at this rate only you can pay
it on one site if you have the provision
so that's why they have the second graph
here that illustrates what happens if
they decide to inject a little more
funds maybe don't spend so much on you
don't you see movies and all that kind
of thing okay so let's have a look at is
a couple of missions by how many must is
the loan reduced by paying that extra
$50 okay so we try to compare these two
here so have a look you can see time on
the horizontal axis down there
it's the dependent variable so how long
to take on the regular 1,000 $79 $99 per
month yeah you're going to end over here
if the 300 month is when the balance is
zero does that make sense okay so we try
to bring it down to there or the other
here is we go by the faster way it's
going to take 279 so what's the
difference 21 months okay so this your
birthday that wasn't hard to read so
we're looking for a horizontal distance
here because we're looking at the time
axis and there are too much at that time
this is what you leave your calculator
for how much you saved all the total
cost of the would you pay off faster but
you have to pay off more as you're going
right so how would we work out what's
actually being expended on the original
version the first graph the original
amount of in Solvers how I get how much
is actually been paid off
yeah good we've got a an actual
installment over here and we know how
many times that's a paler do you go
ahead didn't calculate that in fact what
I've encouraged you to do is it you're
working this is your first line so what
am i working out here
I'm working out the total that actually
been paid for the original scheme which
is this amount of we can see okay
so Alan suggested this is how many times
the person pays and this is how much is
paid each time you're going to get a
number of that I'm not actually
interested in the number
I'm interested in what we do with it
what's going to be the next line of
working what am I going to compare this
total to yeah so what if I paid off
faster by paying off a little more extra
each time so you can type anything you
like but I'm just going to call it the
faster one that's what it is after all
cheering 270 no time there's a laser
point out is how many times it is gets
paid to solve it but it's not 1799
anymore it's 1840 not never to be extra
okay again I'm not that interested in
what this number is
what's the answer why how am I going to
combine these numbers I just I just want
the difference Turner so you can
subtract R this time I am interested in
that about
someone got another anyway 8:21 okay
yeah let's just pause your we leave this
question whenever we work the numbers
like this I always always asked you to
do a tense chatter that's a big amount
of money what would these amounts now
that we've got this down what will
remain a ballpark all they're in like
that where there's a 500 settlement 500
something thousand right there's fine
certain something thousands sound like
it's a sensible nod money if you
borrowed this and the answer is yes one
of the main things that I want to get
across to to fo5 but when I first did
that to you like a little while ago
you're like I ain't serious that's an
insane amount of money but if you can
get used to feeling oh yeah that's how
much you'll actually pay off if that's
how much you borrow they're good
that's whatever the instruments do it is
a reasonable savings and sounds like
it's about right what ways you can work
this out you think about because what's
happening is if you want to figure out
this way this is really a $50 annuity
isn't it it's a $50 that get paid on an
extra monthly basis and this is what is
going to grow into you can go ahead and
you can check the future value so if you
like it works in exactly the same way